y
[Música]
fervor de los manifestantes contra la
extrema derecha son miles los que se han
reunido este sábado en parís y en otras
ciudades francesas
todos ellos preocupados porque ma jin
lepén esté a las puertas del poder
no vale pn en el elíseo se escuchan las
arengas en las pancartas los mismos
mensajes llamando a los jóvenes a
bloquear la agrupación nacional sin
embargo sin llamar sistemáticamente al
voto por macro no tienes que elegir el
enemigo contra el que quieres luchar
durante el próximo mandato y está claro
que hay que elegir yo elijo mantener la
democracia para poder seguir luchando
los próximos cinco años
no soporto que la extrema derecha llegue
al poder y espero vivir eso en mi vida
la situación desde este punto de vista
me parece dramática
una semana antes de la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales este
escenario es tomado muy en serio por los
manifestantes a la cabeza de las
procesiones sindicatos y organizaciones
como ese o ese racismo o la liga de los
derechos humanos han venido a defender
las libertades la justicia y la igualdad
ahora en peligro según los organizadores
lleva el fascismo y una mentira social
muy fuerte y estamos aquí para
denunciarlo cuando vemos el destino que
reserva a los extranjeros los ataques a
las mujeres los lg betis es inmenso los
riesgos están en todas partes
en parís se produjeron algunos
enfrentamientos entre los manifestantes
y la policía
las autoridades consideran que la
concentración es arriesgada porque la
procesión reuniría a varios
manifestantes incluidos los chalecos
amarillos y manifestantes radicales